>> ♪ ♪
>> I WAS WALKING INTO A
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
THAT WAS IN DRAMATIC NEED OF A
MAJOR OVERHAUL.
IN SHORT, WE NEEDED TO REBUILD.
WE NEEDED TO ORGANIZE.
WE NEEDED TO MODERNIZE.
WE NEEDED TO WIN.
I COME TO YOU ABOUT 21 MONTHS
SINCE THAT DATE, AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS BACK.
>> Shannon: THE DNC CHAIR THERE.
OUR PANEL IS BACK.
THEY WILL MEET TOMORROW AND WE
HAD A HEATED EMAIL OVER THE
WEEKEND ABOUT HOW THEY WILL USE
OR SHARE DATA.
CHRIS, THERE ARE INTERNAL
DIFFERENCES?
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE BADLY
OUTGUNNED ON THEIR DATA
OPERATION.
HILLARY CLINTON, SHE LEFT A DNC
THAT WAS A LAUGHABLE SHELL.
SHE RAN HER CAMPAIGN THROUGH
BROOKLYN.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TEAMED UP
WITH THE RNC.
THEY HAVE A ROBUST DATA
OPERATION.
THEY HAVE A TRACK RECORD TO
PROVE THEY CAN TAKE IT TO THE
FIELD.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE STUMPED ON.
THIS YOU HAVE THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE THAT SAYS, SCREAMING
WE ARE IN HUGE TROUBLE.
HE IS GETTING THE STATE CHAIRMAN
SAYING WE ARE NOT SHARING OUR
DATA WITH US.
PEREZ IS FRUSTRATED.
THEY ONLY HAVE WEEKS TO RAMP UP
THE DATA OPERATION ONCE THEY
HAVE A NOMINEE.
>> Shannon: ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ CONGRESS-WOMAN
ELECT TWEETED THIS IS A TERRIBLE
IDEA TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION.
>> THERE MAY BE COMPETING
FINANCIAL INTEREST.
ONE NOT A PRIVATE FUND TO HANDLE
IT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY DIDN'T WORK
OUT WELL IN 2016.
IT WAS MAKING SURE HILLARY
CLINTON WAS THE NOMINEE.
THAT ANGERED THE MORE
PROGRESSIVE WING.
WHO CONTROLS THE ASSETS CONTROLS
THE DIRECTION OF THE PARTY.
DO YOU GO FOR A 50 STATE
STRATEGY OR LET PEOPLE
EXPERIMENT.
>> Shannon: CHRIS, WE THINK
ABOUT UNDER PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA AND CANDIDATE BARACK
OBAMA.
THIS IS LOOKING BACK ON THIS.
THIS IS FROM A DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST.
>> WE AS DEMOCRATS THOUGHT WE
HAD A SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGE IN
DIGITAL AND TARGETING DATA AND
THAT STUFF AHEAD OF THE 2015
ELECTION.
WE WERE LAPPED BY THE TRUMP
OPERATION ON THIS.
>> Shannon: HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> IT'S OVER MY HEAD.
I AM IN THE GENERATION THAT
DOESN'T KNOW THAT MUCH ABOUT
DATA.
PART WHAT HAVE WENT WRONG WITH
HILLARY CLINTON AND DATA, THEY
MODELLED THE ELECTORATE THE WONG
WAY.
THIS IS INSIDE BASEBALL TO
VOTERS.
WHO HAS THE DATA.
WE ARE NOT EVEN IN 2019 LET
ALONE 2020.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THE REPUBLICANS
ARE BLASTING THIS STORY OUT TO
JOURNALISTS.
THE TRUTH IS TOM PEREZ IS RIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE BACK.
THEY JUST WON A BIG VICTORY AND
PUT THE REPUBLICANS BACK ON
THEIR HEELS IN THE LAST FALL.
THE FRUSTRATION OF TOM PEREZ
MUST BE WE ARE GOING GREAT.
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
I PRESIDED OVER THE VICTORY
WOULD BE HIS POINT.
WHY AREN'T YOU LISTENING TO ME
AND FOLLOWING MY SUGGESTIONS?
MOLLY HAS A PART.
PART OF WHAT IS GOING ON IS THE
LINGERING DISTRUST OF THE DNC
LEFT OVER FROM THE FIGHT BETWEEN
BERNIE AND HILLARY CLINTON.
I THINK DEMOCRATS OTHER THAN
THIS SPAT ARE DOING WELL.
>> Shannon: I HEARD A NUMBER OF
DELEGATES ON THE FLOOR WHO ARE